I think about this a whole whole lot you
know
the way I communicate a lot of
confidence a lot of competitiveness a
lot of bravado but the reality is
it is humility that makes me happy it is
humility that actually allows me to
perform its humility like when you
actually realize at the end of the day
you're just one person out of eight
billion who's here for hopefully 100
years and then everything just [__]
moves on when you focus on that truth
when you don't get high on your own
Supply when you don't read your own
press clippings when you just keep it
basic when you just understand the
actual truth of life you win and so the
power of humility don't get it twisted
that doesn't mean you can't have high
energy be
really really focused be competitive
have High Spirit doesn't mean being
passive or chill or not caring but it
means leaning into the really equal
power of confidence and humility